there is a mythology i think among
mushroom takers
that of the saucer of the animated
quality that this thing is intelligent
and that it desires a symbiotic
relationship with
man and it's not hard to see why because
it's a real breakthrough for a species
to cut a deal
with human beings then you come in from
the cold
you're no longer subject to the
vicissitudes of darwinian selection
you've become a domesticated plant
from now on or animal from now on your
fate
is entirely linked to the fate of all
the other domesticated plants and
animals and
their husbandmen the human race and so
for a plant to become to go from a wild
crop to being a food crop
virtually ensures its survival into the
untold
future so it's a very if you think of
plants and animals as seeking better
adaptive
stances in the environment you could
hardly do better
than to bring yourself to the attention
of human beings and get them
to cultivate you that means when we go
to space
they will go to space when the human
race
leaves the planet we will take thousands
and thousands of plants and animals and
bacteria and fungi and
insects all these things will go with us
we are the point
species for this process of leaving the
planet
but i'm sure from the planetary
ecosystems point of view
uh we're just doing it for all
the other little furry folk and their
friends you know
we're acting for everybody and everybody
will
it will benefit everyone i don't know if
you've been following
this new data that's come out but it's
now pretty clear
that there is a 26 million year cycle of
cometary and fall
on the surface of the earth and that
this is driving evolution in some
sense and it's pretty terrible when it
happens
and it's happened more than once more
than twice
more than half a dozen times it is
somehow part of the dynamics of our
solar system
it has to do with the presence of a star
10 light days from our sun
that is dark but that every once in a
while perturbs
the cloud of cometary material which
lies outside the orbit of pluto
and causes this in-fall of cometary
material
and it's what destroyed the dinosaurs
and it's what
created the tertiary transition and an
extinction in the late jurassic
and many others and the the way they
know this is because they find
very highly quantized
levels of atomic iridium
isotopes of iridium that don't occur
normally on this planet are found in
very thin layers
coincident with fossil records of
extinctions
so i think if you believe in the
overmind or the
or gaia or something like that then
you must believe that it senses the on
the approach
of these crises and
biology must grow very anxious as
one of these million-year periods
approaches in which we can expect you
know two or three
hundred large objects to come reigning
in on the earth
and they are extremely effective at
creating mass extinctions we are right
now at a low
point in that cycle it will be another
12 million years
before it really gets going again but
even at the low points of the cycle
every once in a while something comes
winging in
i don't know how many of you have ever
seen meteor crater in arizona
but that's only 50 000 years old that
was not a large object that was an
object a couple of hundred yards in
diameter
everything within 800 miles of the
impact point
died instantly and the
shock wave that rolled out they estimate
probably
circled three times around the world so
it was you know and that was peanuts
compared to things that have gone on uh
in if you look at larger spans of time
in fact once i had to come it was in
fact before all this came up about
commentary and fall
and all this i was stoned once in the
forest in hawaii
having a conversation with the mushroom
and it rolled around
to what was the most outrageous thing
that human beings
had ever witnessed so you know push this
button
and this movie begins of these people
dark-skinned people bare-assed people
somehow they knew and they were climbing
this pinnacle
some kind of rock outcropping somewhere
i got the feeling it was like
thailand or around chiang mai somewhere
like that
and it was night and they got up on top
of this thing
and looked to the southeast and i was
like one of them or something
and uh i thought
i wasn't sure i mean i thought that the
sky had caught on fire or that it had
exploded and
and meanwhile the voice the overvoice is
explaining
that 700 000 years ago on the outer
band arc of indonesia this object came
down and that we're
seeing it from 3 000 miles distance
because
closer than that nobody lived to talk
about it and this is all
true this is known to have happened this
object came down
it's created these things called
tektites which are raindrop
shaped tiny raindrop shaped pieces of
liquid glass
that were thrown out and hundreds of
miles into the air they find these
things from the himalayas to australia
from southern japan to mauritius
just the splatter in other words from
where this thing
came in so this is
a pump part of the force driving human
human evolution and biological evolution
generally on the planet
catastrophism the fact that the earth is
far less stable than we assume and in
fact it's becoming more and more
unstable
if you look at the fossil record the
last
10 million years have been the most
perturbed and dynamic in the earth's
history
the coming and going of these glacial
sheets
did not happen much before that it is
has to do with the accumulated
perturbations in the in the earth's
rotation if you look at the last million
years
it is the most perturbed of the last 10
million
and if you look at the last hundred
thousand years it is the most perturbed
of all
so the planet is actually accumulating
in stability this is not to say that
it's about to fall to pieces or anything
but simply looked at on the scale of 100
million years
it is it is destabilizing
and this has to do with things like
geomagnetic reversals the gradual
de-spun effect of the moon
and things like that but and the days
have been getting shorter too
having to do with the transfer of
gravitational and tidal energy to the
moon
i think we're about to go that you know
when the comets come
they'll find that man is just a fading
memory
in the fossil record of earth and that
we are long
gone that i i
the major threat to our going to space
is probably
the arms race it also strangely enough
is the major force forcing us into space
it's a strange thing the closer we get
to the goal
the more dangerous the situation becomes
it's almost like moving against a force
field
the prediction of these comets is very
tricky apparently a couple of years ago
at
nasa they held a public conference on
what are called earth crossers earth
asteroids which cross the orbit of the
earth
and all these people astronomers various
people got together it was a five-day
conference and started giving their
papers
and on the second day they classified
everything and kicked the press out and
said you know
enough of this because what the data was
showing
was these things are out there they're
very real
i mean there may be as likely as a
massive soviet attack over the pole
may be an an impact by an object from
space
and certain trajectories of approach
would be very very devastating in other
words if
one comes up be from behind and impacts
the earth at a low velocity we can
probably sustain that
but one which is coming the other way
around the sun
and is lost in the helical light of the
sun
will not only have the uh the increased
velocity imparted to it by having been
gravitationally whipped around the sun
it will also be lost in the solar glare
and we would have you know minutes of
warning
at the highest level i mean you and i
would never know what hit us
but the people at the top would have
three or four minutes of realizing
something was going
to happen and so there have been
proposals for deep space radar networks
and actually strategies for undoing this
there's a rumor that you remember reagan
was very big on
dense pack which was a way of putting
hundreds of missiles together and
and then that was slowly dropped and the
rumor that went around at a certain
level in the scientific community was
the reason dense pack was dropped
was because the cia did feasibility
studies that showed it would be very
easy for the russians on a time scale of
15 years
to deflect an asteroid and take it out
non-nuclear
you know to wipe out the entire american
deterrent capability with a non-nuclear
impact of an asteroid right on the
center of the field
so then they decided that was not the
way to go
but these things are out there leave it
to the military
[Music]
you